[MUSIC PLAYING]
DONG CHEN: Hello everyone.
Welcome to the talk.
My name is Dong Chen.
I'm a tech lead of a
ML Kit team at Google.
I'm here today to talk about
ML Kit, Google's machine
learning SDK for mobile.
I would provide a review
of what ML Kit does
and also what's new since
its inception six months ago.
I also share some tips
and the best practices
to improve performance,
accuracy, reduce
size, and a few other things.
In the end, I will talk
about what we're working on.
Two years ago, Google
CEO Sundar Pichai said,
we will move from mobile-first
to an AI-first world.
The intersection
of these two worlds
means machine
learning on mobile.
In recent years, more
and more mobile apps
are using machine learning
to produce fascinating user
experiences.
With smartphones
becoming increasingly
powerful and capable, more and
more machine learning logic
is shifting from the
server running the cloud
to the mobile device
in your pocket.
Running on-device machine
learning has many advantages.
It's fast, it does not need to
send very expensive RPC costs
and incur long network latency.
It also runs anytime, anywhere
with and without network
connectivity.
It also provides better
protection for user privacy
since the data does not
have to leave the device.
Let me take a quick poll here.
How many of you travel
from outside of California
to attend this Dev Summit?
Wow.
Welcome.
Welcome to Silicon Valley.
I hope you get a chance to visit
Golden Gate Bridge, Fisherman's
Wharf, and also enjoy some
good food at a local restaurant
around the Bay Area.
Talking about food,
my biological watch
tells me it's time for dinner.
So where should I eat?
Well, I will pull out my
phone, ask Google Assistant.
Hi, Google.
I'm hungry.
Any good restaurants
around here?
Google Assistant
uses machine learning
to understand my question
and make recommendation
where to go for dinner around
the area and location I'm
currently at.
When I travel to a
new place, I would
like to take a lot of photos.
And Google Photos
use image recognition
to understand image content.
You can classify photos quickly
into thousands of categories.
You can also detect individual
faces, paths, objects,
text in the photo and then make
them searchable by keywords
or categories later on.
Mobile devices can now
really increasingly
[? suffix ?] the
machine learning tasks.
Last spring, I took my
family to Tuscany in Italy.
We drove around those
beautiful hilltop towns.
In each of the towns,
there are many signs.
But I don't speak
Italian, unfortunately.
I wish that I do.
So how do I know what they mean?
Here is where the Google
Translate came to the rescue.
Google Translate can perform
multiple machine learning tasks
in a single journey.
When I pull out my phone,
pointing the camera at a sign,
it will use optical
capture recognition
to detect the text in the sign.
It will also use natural
language processing
to translate the text from
one language into another.
Finally, it will use speech
synthesis to convert text
into voice and using
speaker to tell me what
the sign is in my own language.
All these tasks involves
machine learning.
Combined, they produce a
seamless and a powerful user
experience.
This all looks great.
But as a developer, how do
I build something like this?
Well, it's doable but not easy.
Machine learning often requires
specialized knowledge and years
of experience and training
in building ML models.
The model training,
a lot of time,
requires a large amount
of good high-quality data.
The mobile device higher
[INAUDIBLE] [? side ?]
has very limited
computing power.
The models running on
a server in the cloud
are often too large or too
complex to run directly
on the mobile device.
You need to spend
a lot of effort
to optimize model
for the mobile usage.
After finally the
app is built, you
need to worry about
how do I deploy?
How do I maintain ongoing
instrumentation of the models?
That becomes another headache.
To tackle all these
problems, we launched ML Kit,
Google's Machine
Learning SDK for mobile,
which helps mobile developers
to build Android and iOS
apps using machine
learning technologies.
ML Kit is aimed at making
machine learning easy
for mobile developers.
Just because you want to use
machine learning on mobile,
it does not mean
you need to worry
about collecting data,
building models, training,
model compression, optimization,
hosting, deployment,
downloading model--
all this headache.
ML Kit will take care
of all this for you.
We provide common turnkey models
that work just out-of-box.
All the models are optimized
for speed, accuracy, as well as
efficiency for
the mobile device.
We provide one consistent API
across both Android and iOS.
It's very easy to integrate
ML Kit with Firebase tools
like remote config
or A/B testing.
For commonly needed
machine learning tasks,
we have Base APIs that come
with pre-trained Google models
that work out-of-box.
Currently there are five
APIs we are supporting.
The test recognition API is
supported on both on-device
and the cloud.
The on-device API can
recognize Latin characters.
And the cloud API supports
a wide range of languages
and special characters.
Face detection is
another API we support,
which can be used to detect
faces in both static image
as well as live video streaming.
Now we also launched
contour detection,
which can help you to identify
different parts of the face
and you can then apply
face mask or filters.
The barcode scanning
can be used to detect
both one-dimensional
two-dimensional barcodes, as
well as a QR code.
Image labeling API can detect
objects of various entities
inside the photo.
This supports both
on-device and the cloud.
The on-device API supports
more than 400 labels,
which cover most of
the common things you
see in photos, while the
cloud API can support 10,000
labels across many categories.
Finally, our landmark API can
recognize well-known places
in the photo, like the White
House or the Eiffel Tower.
If this pre-trained model
does not fit your need
and you are an experienced
developer with the knowledge
and you know how to
build and train models,
you're more than welcome to
bring your own custom model.
We run custom models
on TensorFlow Lite.
As you might know, TensorFlow
is the open-source framework
for machine learning.
And TensorFlow Lite is
a lightweight version
of TensorFlow optimized
for mobile platforms.
For models trained
with TensorFlow,
we provide you tools
to convert and compress
into a format compatible
with TensorFlow Lite.
While you're using a custom
model, you have two options--
either bounded inside your
app or hosted in the cloud.
If you choose the latter
option to host in the cloud,
it does not mean you need to
build your own cloud server.
ML Kit and Firebase will
provide a way for you.
We will manage the model
hosting, deployment,
downloading, upgrade, as well
as the ongoing experimentations.
Since ML Kit was launched
six months ago at Google I/O,
we have made several
enhancements.
First, we greatly enhanced
our face detection models,
which is now 18 times faster
and 13% to 24% more accurate.
We also polished our
text recognition API
by making them more
streamlined and consistent
across both on-device
and the cloud.
In addition, we launched
133-point face contour
detection.
As shown in this
image, you can see,
now you can use our face
contour detection API
to identify the contours of
various parts of your face
or anyone's face in the photo.
And that includes
the entire face--
both eyebrows, eyes,
nose, and the lips.
This is where the real-time apps
can put a customer face mask
and the filters--
like a goggle or
some funny nose--
on the face, and
make the mask move
with the face in
live video streaming.
Next, I'm going to share
some tips and best practices
for how to use ML
Kit so that I can
build impressive mobile
apps using on-device machine
learning.
First of all, I will
share a couple of tips
for achieving best accuracy.
There are two things
you should make sure.
One, you should take a very
sharp and well-focused image.
Poor image focus can
really hurt the accuracy.
Second, you should
ensure the options
you want to detect in the
image has sufficient size.
For example, for face detection,
you should have at least 100
by 100 pixels for each face.
And if you want the contour
detection, in the selfie mode,
for example, then the face
should be 200 by 200 pixels.
For the text API
for Latin languages,
each character should be
at least 16 by 16 in size.
And if you use our cloud
API to detect and recognize
Chinese, Japanese, and
Korean, then each character
in those oriental languages
should be at least 24 by 24.
Similarly, barcodes also
have the size requirement.
Please check out our online
documentation for more details.
Machine learning and
libraries can be large, which
can slow down the app download.
There are two ways to
reduce the APK size.
First, you can build your
app as a Android App Bundle.
By doing that, you enable Google
Play to automatically generate
APKs for specific screen
density, CPU architecture,
as well as the languages.
Then your users only
have to download
the APKs and native call
libraries that match
their device configuration.
Another way you
can reduce APK size
is, if the machine learning
feature on your app
is not the primary
purpose, then you
could move machine
learning features which
requires the ML Kit into
a dynamic feature module.
In that way, you'll
prevent users
from unnecessary
downloading ML models,
which can sometimes be large.
We all know machine learning
involves a lot of computation.
So the speed becomes
really important.
Here are some tips how you
could improve the performance
especially for real-time
inference on streaming video.
You can reduce the image
resolution as well as
the video frame rate to limit
the amount of computation
it involves to the inference.
With the current
frame stream process,
you should also throttle
incoming video frames
to avoid any backup,
which increases memory
as well as slow down
the performance.
For real-time face
detection, you
should use fast mode, which
likely is the default mode.
Oftentimes 480 by
360 resolution is
sufficient for face detection.
For real-time processing,
you should also
choose between contour
detection versus classification
or landmark detection,
but not both because doing
both could be
expensive and may not
be fit for real-time
processing in a slow device.
Another tip and
trick you should use
is, you should
wait for detection
to finish before rendering
the face and contour together.
You can check out our
online QuickStart sample app
on GitHub for more details.
To illustrate what I mean,
I will do a live demo.
Let's switch to the demo mode.
So for the purpose of demo, I'm
using a slower 3-year-old Nexus
5X phone, because using
the latest Pixel phone,
the differences are
not as prominent.
In the first video,
I'm going to show you
without any performance tips.
And we do not do
videos throttling.
We do not do any drawing to make
sure the contour and the face
are together.
So if you just call the
API without any performance
improvement, you can
see the contours are not
following the face.
And there's a big gap
between these two.
All right, so now I'm going
to switch to another version
after applying performance tips.
In this version, it's using
the exact same Nexus 5X phone,
but we throttle the
incoming video frame
when we're still processing
the current frame.
And also we wait
for the detection
to finish before rendering
both the face and the contour.
As you can see now, the
contours are following the face
all the time.
They match each other.
There's no more gap.
So let's switch
back to the slides.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
If you're using our class model
API, how to include a model
becomes something
you should consider.
There are two ways.
You can either bundle
the model inside your app
or host it on the cloud.
If you bundle your
model in your app,
it is available immediately.
It also does not require
any model downloading.
So it works offline.
But the downside is
you get a bigger app
because the app
contains the model.
It may slow down
the app download.
Also, you cannot change
the model without a new app
release.
On the other hand, if you
host the model in the cloud,
we provide all the
hosting support for you.
You get a smaller app size
because the app itself does not
contain the model, which
translates into a faster
installation.
You also can choose the download
model only if it's needed.
The model updates
can come over the air
into the app without
any new app release.
You can also use remote config
and A/B testing framework
provided by the Firebase
to do phase rollout
as well as control the pilots.
The drawback of hosting
the model on the cloud
is obviously it
needs connectivity.
When there is no connectivity,
you cannot download the model.
Also the model will
not be available
until they are downloaded.
So a third option is
using a hybrid approach.
You can bundle the
initial version
of the model in the app.
So it will make it usable
right away after installation.
Then you can receive
model updates
over the air from the cloud.
If you are using
our base API, it's
providing in two
different forms.
For the lack of
better terms, I call
it thick SDK and the thin SDK.
In the thin SDK, the
model is actually
provided by the Google
Play service, which means
they're shared across all apps.
The app itself does not have
to contain the model, which
will make your app smaller.
Text recognition and the
barcode scanning APIs
are provided through
the thin SDK.
The second type is
called thick SDKs.
The models are
bundled inside SDK.
Each app will have their
own copy of the model, which
will increase the app size.
Face detection
and image labeling
are supported through
the thick SDKs.
To use these two types of SDKs
and use various APIs provided
by the ML Kit, you need to
include the appropriate ML Kit
dependencies in your
app-level build.gradle file.
Inside that file-- inside
this dependency section--
if you want to use the API
support through the thin SDK,
you should add the dependency
called Firebase-ml-vision.
And in addition, if you
want to use thick SDK,
you should still keep this line,
because automation API entry
points are coming from
this thin SDK dependency.
But you also need to add
additional dependencies.
For example, if you want
to use image detection,
then you need to add the
Firebase-ml-vision face model
dependency because
it's a thick SDK.
Similarly, for image labeling
if you're using that feature,
then you need to add image
label model dependency.
Next, I will talk
about a few new areas
we are currently working on.
A few new ML Kit features
are either under development
or in early testing phase.
We expanded beyond Vision
starting with natural language
processing with Smart Reply.
Smart Reply is a
feature which can
enable you to produce
meaningful responses based
on the current
conversation context.
We are also planning to go
into other areas, like speech.
At the same time, we'll
continue to enhance performance
and accuracy of base APIs.
We launched model compression
and conversion service
to our alpha users, which
help them to convert
and compress large models into
smaller and faster versions
for mobile usage.
The conversion service,
currently [? saying ?] alpha,
uses pruning quantization,
distillation,
as well as to transfer learning
to retrain the large models
and make them smaller and
faster without sacrificing
too much accuracy.
Fishbrain is a
community-based app.
It enables the user to share
the photos of their catch
within their social networks.
With the machine learning
model, it can identify any fish
with just a photo.
When they first came
to us, their model
is more than 80 megabytes.
By using our conversion
and compression service,
they're able to trim down
the model to under 1 meg.
As you can see, they not only
maintain same-level accuracy,
it's actually slightly better.
If you are interested in trying
out our model compression
service, please join our alpha
program by signing up today
at g.co/firebase/signup.
No matter if you are
new to machine learning
or experienced AI expert, I
hope you enjoyed the talk today
and can take home some tips.
And I can't wait to see what
you will build with ML Kit.
If you have any questions,
I will wait outside
in the [? Ask Android ?] lounge.
And we also have
office hours tomorrow.
Thank you very
much for listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]